Isaac, you have been through so much with Bran.
It's just such a, can you just do us a favor?
Because the story arc for Brand is one of he most
incredible I think in the entire show.
Can you summarize for us
his story arc?
It sort of started off as this happy-go-lucky kid,
and it's all looking great.
He likes climbing walls.
And then he sort of catches a bit of incest.
(laughing)
Straight out the window.
There go the legs.
And then alright, his family have now left,
one hurdle after the other.
Thinks he can move on then his house gets burned down.
He has to leave Winterfell,
starts having these weird dreams,
meets some strange guy from his dreams,
who he's never met before,
who tells him to go north to some tree cave.
(laughing)
He has to send his brother off, makes it up north.
Ah, we're near the cave, that's great.
Then some zombies come and kill everyone.
(laughing)
Get in the cave, it's like right,
okay we've been through the wars now, we're safe.
Then the entire army of the dead come to the cave.
Hodor's gone.
Has to leave the cave.
(crowd awing)
Meets his weird, half zombie uncle
who's been missing for six seasons.
He then leaves them again.
And then we find him at the wall,
very confused and traumatized.
It's a typical adolescence I think.
(laughing)